I the audience won't be able to hear the
music you're playing right now no you're
playing like elevator music or well I
you need to know that it's it's like
Japanese grocery store music it's like
it's like the really chill relaxed music
they would play at the end of a happy
Godzilla film around the 70s or it's
like it's like slice-of-life anime music
from like 1991 yeah it's like it's the
music that plays when nothing violent is
happening in like Dragon Ball yeah and
you're and you're still playing okay is
it stops is it over
are we free from this hell this is why
why we took a break man all right we're
back everyone after all this time they
hate us because they ain't us and also
because we went on hiatus but anyway
I've been working very hard and I'm
doing the job that I was given okay I'm
okay don't go looking for me like that
thing where we're Fan Bingbing the
Chinese actress who was the portal lady
in x-men Days of Future past was
arrested because of tax evasion and now
she had to she was kept in a Chinese
prison and then she had a Paul had to
apologize for the Chinese government and
pay like eighty million dollars in back
taxes China is [ __ ] scary like I
don't think we talked about it enough as
a country but like China is a spooky
place cuz like don't they I can't
remember don't they like just like
execute people who are uh you know
charged with like drug trafficking or
sale that's the Philippines
okay the Philippines yeah
I was pretty sure I saw a documentary
once about Hong Kong Rose about some guy
getting like like caught with like like
meth in his car and then getting
sentenced to being executed
that's the Philippines Wow you know I
know someone from there that I could ask
so do you want this so you know the the
guy who directed the raid movies yeah
he's gonna movie out he was gonna direct
uh
he's gonna direct his death stroke and
then DC didn't know what they were doing
so they were like a [ __ ] does not
make that one which they thought was
like twenty movies he's got a new movie
out for Netflix what's it called
apostille does it have the same kind of
action sequences it's a horror movie Oh
about the about a guy who uses kung fu
to kill people
no it's about that guy from Legion going
to a remote island where his sister has
been kidnapped by a mysterious religious
cult so like kind of like The Wicker Man
yes wait which guy from Legion is
Allegiant himself or somebody himself
Dan Oh Stevens that guy is a cool actor
I like him and stuff he was also in
colossal where he played a [ __ ]
boyfriend well he came back at the end
well compared to the other [ __ ]
boyfriend in that movie he's
comparatively a decent guy well cuz he
came back in the end also the reason he
was an [ __ ] is because his girlfriend
was more of an [ __ ] and he was just
like tired of it it was justifiable
[ __ ] er II also colossal is a good
movie you should check it out if you
like kaiju [ __ ] and also indie movies
from like 1990 what is this music you're
playing now it's called sounds for the
supermarket it sounds
it's driving me insane it's like someone
is like deepthroating a slide whistle
[Laughter]
that ain't no flute yeah that's a crime
against humanity is what you're playing
I don't want to go into any supermarket
that's playing that [ __ ] oh my god is
this it is that are you playing the
trailer for this yeah oh man of course
they named the character Thomas because
what else do you name an old-timey guy
played by Dan Stevens who was in Downton
Abbey he was also in Beauty and the
Beast and he played Emma Watson in that
film he did a great job yeah yeah [ __ ] I
thought he couldn't pull off that
performance but you know what he proved
me wrong let's be honest see he is a he
is beautiful enough to play battle he's
actually a quite attractive man and I
think it was a I think it was a daring
decision of the filmmakers to gender
bend the whole thing oh yeah yeah and
really it wasn't like a really really
lifeless on creative remake of the
original at all no no it wasn't it
wasn't just a point for point like
shot-for-shot remake but in live action
but stupider I took a girl on a date to
see that movie suffice to say I did not
call her back you know I think I was
trying to push to go see some horror
movie that day cuz like she was a really
Goffe girl who had all kinds of tattoos
and like like wore black makeup all the
time and had dyed her hair black like
she just looked so like you know edgy
and like kind of emo girl and I was like
hey you want to see this horror movie
this weekend or whatever or or it was it
was life I think so Ryan Reynolds and
Rachel Mickey
it was either that or some other movie
that came out that that around that time
but since she's like actually I really
wanted to see Beauty and the Beast cuz I
I didn't like Disney films and then she
I looked closer at her tattoos and they
were of Disney characters and I was like
wait a minute
that's wienie the Pooh that's not a
skull you're not Punk you're just just
monochromatic Disney girl oh I bet she
had a horse phase she's one of those
girls I'm not like other girls I'm not
like other girls I like horses no other
girl likes no other girl has ever gone
through a horse face my cousin had the
worst horse phase of any girl I ever
knew because at one point she just
[ __ ] owned a horse so what is the
male equivalent to a horse girl probably
a car guy you know like it starts out
when they're young and they just have
this [ __ ] weird-ass obsession with
like Hot Wheels like don't get me wrong
I had plenty of Hot Wheels tracks I was
playing with those all day but like I
wasn't like sexually aroused by them no
no I wasn't like you were only sexually
aroused by the by the bulging muscular
venom in your ear room I have so many
action figures of venom with his bulging
muscles
hey venom came out I haven't seen it
it's pretty good surprisingly and kind
of upsettingly cuz like you liked alien
covenant okay
I think alien covenant has some severe
problems but it's still watchable I
would say venom is better than alien
covenant because like hot tip question
okay guilty pleasure Estill T pleasure
movie that came out in the last few
years
I even consider venom like a guilty
pleasure like I don't even I don't like
there's nothing really that bad about it
that makes me not okay alright um I'm
trying to think you really put me on the
spot here uh I didn't enjoy any of the
last couple Transformers movies I know
those are the kind of like the go-to for
that genre [ __ ] I I'm having a really
hard time picking you know I kinda the
music I was starting to hate it it at
first like sounds for Super Market six
1975 grocery store music is what he's
playing right now I was mad about it at
first but it's actually kind of soothing
and I feel like it helps the
conversation flow a little better if we
have like a rhythm and I
I kind of want him to not stop playing
it now
can you like leave it in the Vinland can
you record some of this grocery store
music and then have it in the video in
the background
it's possible but copyright well okay
who's gonna copyright sounds for the
grocery store 1975 surprised who the
[ __ ] cares you would be surprised oh my
god there's probably some company who's
just trying to scrape like three cents
off of that probably owned by like it's
probably owned by some really surprising
company - that doesn't make sense like
like it's you you play it in the
background of our podcast and you get a
like a copyright from like like
Paramount Pictures and you're like what
the [ __ ] really them they own them no I
think it would be more interesting if
you got a copyright strike from a
Kroger's mine which Kroger's would stop
emailing me all the [ __ ] time because
I tried to get a job at a grocery store
once and then like it didn't work but
they still go Kroger
job notifications and then like you can
subscribe I thought I did but then I
still kept getting them anyway and it's
also on my alternate email so I don't
really check it that often
but every time I open it up it's just
like 60 new messages from Kroger and I'm
like wow why why why are you like this
I'm gonna not buy any more products from
Kroger ads that's it that's my new my
new mandate in addition to no longer
purchasing any Marvel Comics event story
ever no matter what it is I'm also going
to not eat anything from Kroger I
suppose I'm gonna not eat anything at
all if they don't let me out of this
[ __ ] bathroom at some point so at
least you have a toilet right no no
there's no toilet there's just a hole in
the floor there's no toilet well it's
not bad well it has a bathtub in a sink
but I don't know if they work and
there's no showerhead also the walls are
really chipped up and gross in here I'm
surprised I wake up in the middle of the
night covered in cockroaches be careful
what you wish for
oh god no they're called the arachnid
conglomerate not not the cockroach
conglomerate the [ __ ] dawn is what they
would call themselves for short instead
of the conglomerate like you're you're
just you're just playing this this music
mu za k music I know where you listening
that's literally what this is can you a
I want you to figure out which of these
is like not copy written and then put it
in the back of the the video cuz it's
actually kind of fun it I feel like
it'll fill some of our dead space a
little better hello
segues mmm nailed it catch us next
weekend where we
strimm some dead space we're gonna
stream some dead spouse channel on what
day I don't know can we try for Saturday
maybe I have to be on some kind of
spider-man themed jeopardy on Sunday I
have a feeling I'll do better than you
to hope not as well as you'd expect you
to do this it's more like they kind of
permit it they let me do like whatever I
want as long as it's spider-man related
what about Spider Woman related I I
haven't asked why won't you I cuz I'm
afraid cuz they have this [ __ ] lead
pipe that they sometimes threaten hit me
with that's just I mean come on
man I would be more concerned when you
were kidnapped which will probably
happen at some point
who would I be kidnapped by Wow
you ever been to like Detroit Michigan
it's like you could like go down any any
random alley and get kidnapped
I think Brandon's from there I know for
a fact he isn't but I still think it's
funnier to pretend that he is are you
skipping ahead through the music because
I feel like it keeps starting over what
are you doing will you stop it just
leave just let it play stop hitting the
button and make it go further for [ __ ]
sake
he's just pressing some button to make
it rewind like six seconds and then go
forward six seconds he's ruining my flow
here this this music is the most
soothing thing I've heard and I don't
know sixteen days is that when I was
taken
the guards escort me down to some like
kitchen area downstairs occasionally all
wear masks I don't know what they look
like they don't speak much I feel like
maybe there's someone that I know and if
I heard their voice I'd be able to know
who they are
there's a reason where the guys don't
speak around you cuz they all know you I
know some of the guys I know that they
have chips and soda downstairs they have
so much dr. pepper downstairs olive
liver I don't know why they they just
have cases and cases of it it's you
won't let me have any exactly that's
part of the torture is it is that they
keep having it so that you're set you're
so you can smell all the time well I get
is the bread and the water and you can
smell the dr. pepper and you can hear
them drinking it you can hear them going
that's some good dr. pepper
so I heard you say I saw a movie
recently what did you think of a star is
born I didn't see that did you no I just
think you did why would you think that I
saw that because I think you did why do
you sound like you're accusing me now
because you deserve it okay are you one
of them is this just part of the thing
is like like your your your the Iraq and
conglomerate and you is just a ploy to
get me to start recording the podcast
again to capture me well let's just say
I'm not I'm not part of the arachnid
conglomerate but I know them and I gave
them my go-ahead so so you're not like a
member yeah but you don't have any
problems with the people who are exactly
nice um really smooth jazz you got
playing
some really smooth jazz
cheer about that Venom burger that they
make where's that I can't remember I
just know I just I I know that they made
a cheeseburger that looks like venom I'm
gonna send you a picture of it to you
why would they let me add it on a laptop
that's from like 2010 it's a [ __ ]
movies or laptop because they hate you
well you know it would make my my thing
that I have to do go a little faster if
I had better equipment guys okay okay
I'm sorry I'm sorry alright sorry yeah
they didn't like that that is the most
disgusting looking bigger burger I've
ever seen in my life I knocked a bunch
of [ __ ] off of the sink I just like not
can you just not eat that burger well I
wasn't going to anyway no no you don't
need anything that that isn't made of
tofu you know you know you tofu so
anyway telltale games closed down I
believe today is actually the 10th
anniversary no no okay I was like
Telltale's like almost 20th anniversary
as a company but a couple weeks ago but
the fifth anniversary of the wolf among
us which I will still defend to the
death is the best telltale video game
and I I mean can you name one video game
you haven't done that with um let me
pull up my Steam page like just like
name off a bunch of games you've like
played beginning to end and actually
beaten while you do that I'm just gonna
say that uh I'm really sad that telltale
went under
I'm sad to find out that they apparently
didn't pay any of their employees I wish
I could get paid for what I'm doing okay
all right sorry sorry sorry okay but
anyway you know um you know they say
when they say wage slavery that's what
you are
there's no wages it's just slavery I'm
surprised they haven't shamble me to
this [ __ ] pipe sticking out of the
ground so I'll go down let's see Ann Lee
and isolation I played two hours of you
you didn't beat alien isolation you
played two hours of it which considering
that game you might have just barely
seen the alien for the first time yep
I I think I got pretty close to
finishing Batman Arkham origins
[Music]
Bioshock is poop
cities skylines is pretty open-ended but
since I put over 100 hours into it I
think we can say I pretty much finished
in it yeah Bobby I guess yeah I finished
doki-doki literature Club see stringer
and Skyrim I think we can say I finished
that for thee did you beat the main
quest and Skyrim remember honestly I've
got over a hundred hours in Fallout New
Vegas so yes new vegas is apparently the
best Fallout game it is I've it's so
weird
I've I've only played like the first
like ten minutes of new Vegas and then
got bored and turned it off but I've
played like all of Fallout 3 multiple
times knowing full well that it's way
worse you idiot I'd be I'm sorry Batman
- and let go Batman and then Lego Star
Wars The Complete Saga I got pretty
close to winning Lego Batman 3 is the
best one because it's basically not a
Batman game it's a Justice League game
that just heavily features Batman I just
finished portal 1 in portal 2
I've finished rollercoaster tycoon 2 I
don't know if anyone else agrees in deep
ok can I ask me any questions
and ask you a question Wow was Lego
Batman one annoying as [ __ ] because you
had to keep switching out into dumb
alternate costumes for Batman because
they wrote themselves into a corner and
couldn't give you a video game that
allowed you to play as a lot of
different characters really I remember
as a little kid I was so pissed off
because I didn't want to be Batman with
magnet boots or Robin one with [ __ ] a
diving suit I wanted to just be Batman
and Robin yeah - like a Batman - you
know I have it I don't think I've beaten
it it's good isn't it kind of like the
precursor to Lego Marvel where you can
actually explore around Gotham yeah I
think I played like the first mission of
it and then got bored and then went back
to playing Lego Batman 3 Rob scrubs
animate
you listen to these doesn't he I maybe I
could ask him well if he does then
you'll hear this that you called him a
loser
yes don't man don't push him he's gonna
edit a really really impressive 3d
animation of you getting like railed by
Captain Kirk damn it I was hoping I
could say something that would like like
scare you off but I think that just got
you more excited to mess with him
messing with sasquatch him too
what a weird ad campaign for what
alright for the the beef jerky is where
they just would find Sasquatch out in
the woods and then just harass him so
here's how much and then suffer
occlusion consequences exactly 73
minutes 73 mmm-hmm
and I've put like on my Steam account
I've put in to 60 hours into Star Trek
Online and if you add that in with mine
on Steam play of that is probably like
close to want 200 hours I miss wolf
among us it was really good it was you
know what I think the reason that the
Walking Dead telltale games started to
kind of fall off a little in quality is
because the Walking Dead is a premise
that lends itself well to a short story
and not a very long one like like Robert
Kirkman initially was like the reason I
wanted to do a long-form zombie story is
because they always kind of cut him
short it's always like a one-off movie
about this group of survivors or it
always like has them all die at the end
or something he's like I want to like
see like the day-to-day operations and
and continuing Adventures of a group of
survivors in a zombie apocalypse but
then I figured out that I think he might
have too and is too ashamed to admit it
is that there's a reason why zambie
apocalypse stories usually don't last
super long and why the I the whole idea
doesn't lend itself well to an extremely
long story because we're on my talking
about it I'm totally excited for season
9 of Walking Dead do you know who's not
the [ __ ] lead actor who's leaving the
show because he's so tired of it you
know he says he wanted to go back to
England to be with his family but I
think that's code for I'm sick of being
stuck on this [ __ ] TV show that's
like not very good it's like hurting my
career now cuz it's not as popular as it
was in 2011 you know that Frank Darabont
is still suing AMC for that show do you
read his emails No
okay for those who don't know Frank
Darabont was the showrunner for
dead during season one he had a lot of
really ambitious and crazy ideas he's
alleging like unpaid royalties and
everything well okay so they're it's a
complicated situation cuz like he
brought in a whole bunch of his like
personal life friends that are actors to
have them like as the cast of the show
like like actors that were in his
previous works like the fog like it was
all people he was used to working with
on the cast he he had a lot of new ideas
that he worked into the show cuz he
thought like the idea was good but could
be better so he he he added like this
really explosive like epic action II
climax to the first season that actually
made it really interesting and cool and
kind of you know put the scope of the
zombie epidemic into a little bit more
clearer terms so he and his agents have
filed the lawsuit against MCC for more
than two hundred and eighty million
dollars in unpaid profits now there's
two sides of the story is that some
people on his side like that [ __ ]
vampire guy from being human who's I
guess one of his friends you know
Starkiller that's his name
he was like AMC fired him because he had
too many ambitious ideas that were too
expensive over budget yeah well cuz like
they filmed in the middle of Atlanta
like a whole like six blocks were
cordoned off to just film [ __ ]
zombies like aerial shots for like
multiple episodes straight and it looked
it didn't even look like a TV show it
looked like a movie and it was awesome
so people on his side are just like well
he went over budget and they would
rather hire someone else to run the show
who could who could just like do lame
[ __ ] like have them be on a farm for 12
episodes even though it was only like 10
pages worth of the comic that they were
there
which was wonderful but his emails came
out to like AMC people a couple years
ago um and they were pretty gruesome and
horrendous like he was like like
accusing other people on staff of being
mentally handicapped because they
weren't following his directions he was
using some very flourishing
he was very rude kind of sounded like an
insane person and and then like started
screaming about how he wanted multiple
people fired because he didn't think
their script for a certain episode was
good enough and then he went back and
rewrote it himself like just really
unprofessional behavior so so then they
fired him and then filmed the next 12 12
episodes of just people sitting around
on a farm doing literally nothing in
fact the show got so cheap in season 2
that they didn't even want to film at
night on some days so they just put a
slightly blue filter on scenes that they
shot in the daytime and you can still
see the reflection of the Sun off of the
[ __ ] cars it was insane
but anyway Walking Dead sucks
and I I feel bad for all of the really
talented actors that are on that show
we're stuck under contract because it
would probably be better for them and
their careers as actors if they can move
on to bigger and better things
I want Norman Reedus to play Ghost Rider
in something like a death stranding oh
yeah death straining so cool that's like
what am I like top three most excited
for things coming up in the next like
year I don't know what the other two are
so I guess it's actually top one I'm not
really excited for much anymore I'm
excited for leaving this [ __ ]
warehouse I think it is Derek reenacts
yeah x-men dark meat you know what you I
don't know a thing that I'm excited for
a Wyatt
okay so there's I've been following
these like the the news out of film
festivals and there's this sci-fi movie
called High Life that's written written
and directed by a French woman and it
looks really interesting and you can
tell that it's written directed by a
French woman I'm wondering how you can
like just tell by watching it well
here's the thing it says um it's a movie
about like people in space never drink
your own urine never eat your own [ __ ]
even if they've been recycled murmurs
crew member Monty Robert Pattinson do
the little baby in his care it's what we
call a taboo a taboo taboo taboo he
turns the word into a song and the baby
gurgles these moments of connection
played beautifully played by Pattinson
and a baby are all the more precious
once we realized that the parrot of the
last ones left of Ord a lot of
live-aboard are slowly falling spaceship
unromantic ly designed to resemble
shipping container according to a
jumbled chronology that could be
reflective of time time just before the
title appears over a lyrical even before
the title appears over a lyrical shot of
cruise body's flowing floating down the
inky water space we watch Monty go about
the nasty lonely business of judging his
dead colleagues death row inmates go on
a mission in space to try and extract
energy out of a black hole and then on
the way there's this this witchy doctor
who tries to like do experiments on them
she harvests semen from the men all
except the voluntarily celibate Monty
with whom dibs is consequently obsessed
and inseminates the women in the hope of
creating life out here in the lifeless
irradiated void by the isolation and
dawning awareness of the suicidal nature
of the mission as well as a presumed
predisposition towards violence create a
commune of spiraling despair and madness
among the crew this is mirrored by the
jerky discomforting pace of the film as
a series of long Juris interspersed with
moments of shuddering gory violence rape
and mechanistic masturbation in the
already infamous [ __ ] box a small leaky
room equipped with restraints and piston
mounted dildos in which the inmates of
this loading position prison can relieve
their sexual frustration what the [ __ ]
yes I okay that's what Robert Pattinson
is up to lately yes because he's because
he's got like all the money he needs to
pay the bills from Twilight so you can
just go in he and his being weird stuff
now it's my favorite thing ever that he
hates Twilight he hates its fans and he
hates those just like the entire
experience I mean he broke up with you
know what's her name Kristen Stewart who
is now gay so they all had fun times
after that movie so now he's starring in
weird stuff like you know last city he
was in life not that life Oh what's this
life
oh it's about a life photographer okay
this one it's weird how two movies can
come out like two years apart with the
with an identical title and not have
like brand confusion problems like I get
it when you have like two Hercules
movies come out or like the Jungle Book
but like really just a word just like
life I guess you can't copyright a word
like that you know did you just open
city skylines no what is that that's a
rollercoaster in a mansion you did
didn't you
there you're this is a [ __ ]
rollercoaster village yes oh okay
rollercoaster tycoon you remember thrill
ville no this [ __ ] was my jamm back on
ps2 you can make basically like your
nameless video game character man was
the uh he was like well he or she I
guess since you could create the
character was he she or it or she it she
was the like the the nephew or niece of
some like really famous roller coaster
tycoon man who owned a amusement park
called thrill ville and he was like hey
you want to be in charge of my roller
coasters and amusement parks even though
you're like 12 and you're like yeah so
basically you just run around the park
all day asking people what kind of stuff
they would like and then just like
trying to manage out your budget and
then like you know figure out what you
can you can get to to appease people so
you know you'd add like extra
rollercoasters that you get to build
yourself or you could add like places
for them eat food
who needs to eat food really heavy you
can even add like mini games like they
have like like all kinds of like arcade
games that were really cool that would
just like turn it into like a
first-person shooter game or something
where you're like fighting cowboys or
some some such nonsense or getting
chased by dead by dinosaurs it's really
neat because they've worked in a lot of
cowboys they worked in a lot of
different styles of gameplay into a
single game just because the premise
allowed for like so much it's just
really creative and charming and cute
little game I never actually beat it I
just like I don't know I seem to
remember always getting to like the
third or fourth location where you could
build amusement parks and then I would
always get like tired cuz it didn't seem
like there was a lot of forward momentum
like I don't know if you can beat that
game can you beat that game maybe I
could if I tried it again today but I
don't have ps3 since I'm in a bathroom
no I don't think they'll think it's
relevant enough but anyway um are you
coughing are you ever like respiratory
problems like oh god that would taste so
good right now all I've had is bread you
pervert but anyway um yeah so I I'm just
only really allowed to play that new
game which new game a game I can't read
it I can't is it the new game yeah sure
well the duty I need to call of battle
feel better Joe modern bad company
advanced black cops don't you know there
are no black cops cuz all five cops are
racist and black people can't be racist
I'm actually writing a comic book about
a black police officer no you're not but
he's in space okay so it's fantasy yeah
yeah yeah
I want to sneeze but it won't come out
and it's really [ __ ] up my day
already worse than it was you know what
else will also won't come out you and
wolf among us season two you need to
respond to your masculine owner because
I just called you a gay hey man can't do
this
I'm I'm comfortable in my sexuality I
like the ladies David I feel like you're
projecting a little that's what I do
that's my job
you're a projectionist yeah work that's
how you get to see so many more movies
than I do well that and I have an
internet connection I really want the
music to be in the podcast now because
otherwise the people are gonna like
think we sound [ __ ] crazy well like
it's just gonna sound stupid because
like you listened okay well yeah we've
talked about some weird stuff before
[ __ ] venom now what everyone wants to
[ __ ] venom now oh yeah of course
venom is like the name the new monster
boyfriend icon I mean honestly
like he replaced Dracula what else did
you expect okay well to be fair his two
main powers are having having an
extremely muscular body and tentacles
that go everywhere also a tongue that's
like a foot long and can change shape
and size at his whim he's basically just
a big scary penis monster with a
handsome man inside
if they wanted to avoid having a thirst
community around side your character you
shouldn't have cast Tom Hardy just sing
you know what it annoys me when they do
it with spider-man but whenever I see
like cutesy fanart of Eddie Brock and
venom and like like like the suit and
Eddie are doing like silly weird stuff
like like reenacting Calvin and Hobbes
books or [ __ ] going to like the movie
well no no that fan art exists too and
that's been around long before this but
like I think that their teenage girl
Twitter stands who are good at drawing
also tumblr has seized on Eddie Brock -
but yeah both groups which are different
in slight ways there's a lot of overlap
there's a lot of overlap but they they
do have differences I think both of them
ended up realizing that they're in love
with venom and for some reason it
doesn't bother me in the slightest
because like now that means venom is
gonna just get like more comics and
video games you know
spider-man - I know I know like there's
the okay there's all of the like weird
Tom Hollands stands who just wanna who
don't even care about spider-man they
just wanna [ __ ] Tom little that yeah
they just want to diddle his baby face
by the way I cannot find Tom Holland
attractive in any sense of the word he
looks like a little kid well you're also
it's weird cuz I'm like younger than him
like he's older than I am and I still
look at him and go yeah that's a baby
you know I'm trying to find the right
fanfiction to read no we're not reading
fancy what about I want to taste you
Eddie
so anyway I appreciate that there's a
bunch of weird teenage girls who love
venom now and are drawing to make me why
are you
stop it I looked it so it's mine what
the [ __ ] is that were g-41 oh my god
what venom takes Eddie's body to
surprise reminds me of my ex-girlfriend
from high school she used to have this
weird ass joke that like high school was
like on prison rules so if you want
something to be yours you have to lick
it or spin on it and then she licked me
one day it was like your your mind now
I'm like it's your [ __ ] creepy well
you're you are that creepy no I haven't
licked anybody sure well I mean not
recently
no need to rush oh my god stop it no we
care a parasite
Eddie wakes up with a boner [ __ ] what
but anyway Eddie Brock is fine too like
laying sex with overly sexualized since
he's a big buff manly Chad basically and
not a small child like I don't know it's
just set is sexualizing venom for some
reason just doesn't bother me in the
slightest like it does when they
sexualized spider-man well I mean well
in the in the MCU yes
so the canonically version that all the
twitter stands are thirsting about is
canonically and underage like why not be
[ __ ] weird and creepy about the comic
version who's actually thirty like they
say his age he's thirty now what why not
why not be all thirsty over him he's
fine no okay you want the the little kid
one fine alright
come on Tobey Maguire's chance already
please don't
any pleaded as he watched venom
substance rise from his skin to rap
firmly around his torso Oh Eddie I can
be so much better just having me voice
act for venom since I can actually do a
pretty good job yes you want to read it
you want to read some fanfiction we've
been on hiatus not doing this [ __ ]
podcast for how many weeks now and you
want us to come back with this yes okay
The Guardian do you want to watch do you
want to read Jonah read Eddie wakes up
with the boner venom melts is that the
[ __ ] title no that's the summary okay
I'm gonna send this to you you know this
would be really great if I did I
actually keep the jazz music because
there's like really relaxing jazz music
while we're reading you've made the case
of why we should keep it I've said it I
agree in consent to its terms okay it's
always something you want to see when
you uh you're ready website hang on
are you ready I mean audience I'm I like
how all of Venom's lines are in bold
mm-hmm well at least you you you know
how to read it now yeah it'll be I won't
lose my place now cuz it's actually
really easy to tell where where to read
mm-hm
so so the whole on the notes from the
author says so I saw a venom yesterday
very gay ten out of ten so now I have
joined the ranks of the monster
[ __ ] at least they're honest I can
appreciate that level eunuch lected to
tell me that the summary also has a
Lenny a Lenny face in it monster no
everyone's not listening to the podcast
now we first we didn't do a podcast for
like weeks and now we're just gonna yes
whose channel is this going on by the
way I don't know but I think it might be
yours it isn't it's mine well the last
one was supposed to be on mine but then
that recording got lost I guess so
ah [ __ ] you ready oh oh all right well
anyway
you ready yeah sure
okay it had been some time since Eddie
ga'head got last got laid his condition
over the past six months had not exactly
been the best you just had a hard time
just staying on and now he had a
parasite not a parasite with whom he
shared not only a body but also a mine
and for some bizarre reason this was
comforting comfortable huh and he did
not like admitting this not even for
myself but what he had with venom was
something he had always craved someone
to be there for his good chunk of this
is actually cannon kiss Eddie refers to
the suit and the comics is my love maybe
having venom not when he had this voice
in his head childish and stubborn two
insightful and compassionate and
sometimes seductive
the music stopped and then played again
right as well as your sentence ran it
was so perfect it was not something
anyone had expected by any means but
hearing venom say you know in his deep
voice comfortably in the back it's just
such an unattractive worse boner just
like everything else is so elegantly
written and then just had the word boner
okay
sorry in the first days of their
symbiosis and he had been too out of it
to be anything but confused their
spoilers for the movie I think okay are
you gonna keep breathing and only after
the Drake disaster of their relationship
mental and physical somewhat stabilized
and the more time passed the better they
fit together it been remarkable from the
very start but now they had reached to
say a stage of being one rather than two
beings and sharing a body most of the
time at the thought of venom helping him
Eddie could not suppress a moan that
shot through him he vaguely wondered if
you should feel weird about this but
then venom took control of his arms and
felt his tongue against his neck I don't
want to do a breathy whimper on the
podcast do it I'm not doing a breathy
whimper do it I've already been
kidnapped and severely beaten several
times they're not doing a breath they
went back it's not rude
venom said it feels good
with these words and he felt his hand
reaching to his god venom knew what to
do well we're gonna read the rest of it
and then you edit how my overmuch oh no
we can give that another try
venom muttered and somehow grinned even
broader than usual Jesus Christ a slow
rhythm achingly slow and Eddie needed
more needed more your and no [ __ ] any
press starting to caress his pepperoni
venom sounded too smug for somebody who
knew exactly what Eddie liked anyway of
course I knew it useless parasite even
as the words left his mouth Eddie
regretted having said them his hand in
Venom's tendrils left his banana
materialized on top of him
pressing him into the mattress keeping
in a place with nowhere to go
Oh parasite venom growled I'm sorry
Eddie panted if you were really sorry
you wouldn't keep saving it
venom counter stop just please please
what I need to come
Eddie was getting desperate he thrust up
again there is no friction there welcome
to the unmonitored abba Lana listen I
have a video on my channel called sex
pastries and monsters I know what I'm in
for now why would we do that
as you should thank God the guard can't
hear what's going on in my [ __ ]
headphones the ambiguously gay duo you
can keep that bit Oh Mike the speaking
of Tom Hardy did you know they dug up a
story that Tom Hardy put on MySpace back
in the early to thousands of him saving
a kitten for that was about Dustin's
destined to die in his apartment and it
no in his hotel room even though he
wasn't supposed to have pets in his
hotel room how did he find the kitten
like you know just like dad on the
street like like you know abandoned on
the street or whatever oh and he nursed
it back to health
yeah I stand this man he saved kittens
he actually probably pushed for venom to
be a better movie than it was going to
be do you hear about how he had a big
black meltdown on the set well I heard
that there were some conflicts between
him and the director at one point he
[ __ ] just started screaming and
saying that the script was garbage in
one scene and demanded that they rewrite
it or else he wasn't gonna come out of
his trailer and that like he had like
the writing team like redo a whole scene
because he hated it so much and like
once it was to his specifications he
would finally come out the next day and
read his lines
he also completely ad-libbed this one
scene in like the the restaurant like
kind of near the middle of the movie and
it's actually probably one of the
funniest and most memorable scenes in
the movies movie and he was just like
hey what if I did this and the director
is like I for whatever we're not gonna
put it in the movie they did you lunatic
weirdo right Tom Hardy even an actor so
Tom Hardy is now like I hope all of the
Twitter stands get bored with Tom
Holland and like Tom Hardy instead cuz
Tom Hall on their Twitter stay I'm
haulin hates cats he's a [ __ ] well
there were two there come on there
Twitter stands for for Tom Hardy back
before there was Twitter yeah
but now now there's gonna be even more
venom to basically confirmed at this
point because the box office no.2
electric boogaloo venom to please get
carnage a better wig why I heard the one
in the movie was fine no in women you
know why was it not fine
he looked like Sideshow Bob what's wrong
with Sideshow Bob
I love Sideshow Bob does not look good
in live-action Bob
KITT I wanted to see venom - why not
venom one are you racist or something is
it because there's a brown guy as the
villain man there there was a couple of
big leaps and logic in that one and I
don't think they really gel well
speaking of brown people are you excited
for aladdin directed by Guy Ritchie you
remember how they had a hard time doing
the casting for the movie cuz there's no
Middle Eastern people in Hollywood yeah
and like whenever that was they were
they just get cast as [ __ ] terrorists
mm-hmm but Disney learned a lot from
that one do you think Disney ever learns
their lessons no they don't
they this is the company that released
song of the south
what's that um it's like a like a Disney
animated live-action hybrid but you know
how like but it's also gone the whole
you know it's it's it's an it set but
set in the south and it plays it like
you know the South was great happy time
and there was no racism
in the you know in the pre-war week
pre-war south where there was slavery
it's very you know racially weird
because of that it tries to portray pre
Civil War United States as being a happy
place happy idyllic you know where we're
you know how you have the black man
singing you know it's a wonderful day
and all that it's kind of upsetting to
me how many extremely racist things
Disney has done yes and then on top of
that they'll also fire James Gunn over
tweets that they know this is why
they're there they're doing this is they
they they have a to pretend to history
they never do that history by
overreacting like crazy these days well
their fan base is you know like liberal
white women so of course they have to do
it yeah white women are the worst can
confirm I dated one once and it was
terrible I'm gonna cut a lot of this I
hopes this is the nightmare is there a
joke I she sided for a Phoenix I know
you know what
no one's excited for I am in Dark
Phoenix yeah I was gonna do a video
where I was like hey why is everyone so
unenthusiastic and board about x-men
Dark Phoenix like right like kind of
defending it and then I was so bored
about it that I didn't even end up
making that video I am excited about it
but here but I will agree with you that
the first trailer is garbage but the
first trailer for all x-men movies the
first trailer for all X and movies is
always garbage because they did do the
venom thing and they rush it out before
the VFX is done we were and also the
effects on some telekinesis shots and no
one else's powers up well also they're
doing reshoots right now or at least
very least they were like last two
months so it's about right now when
really wrapped on there's jealous well
well like I mean
they don't say they don't need to tell
you that the the the movie business
prefers that you know as little as
possible about how it works they will
know at this point because of the
internet we know almost everything
exactly but they won't tell you anything
that they don't have to tell you they
want to tell you the embarrassing parts
like hey after CGI Tom Cruise's chest to
not look so grotesque mm-hmm let's let's
be honest who is it who is surprised by
that do you remember at that time where
Paul Rubens was playing Pee wee Herman
again and they had to get a [ __ ]
metal clip to tie his skin back at the
back of his head and then CGI it out and
post mm-hmm it looked [ __ ] he
basically said that if he had gotten
plastic surgery he could have saved the
studio million dollars let's be honest
they got they got money going out the
wazoo they don't need to save money on
Netflix routinely puts out complete
garbage and they pay a lot of money for
that garbage and the end for some reason
just because of their business model
they haven't lost really hardly anything
on any of it mm-hmm like they've just
kind of set themselves up as being able
to just dump money into a billion
worthless projects and then never have
any negative consequences for it
basically yeah so like there's like six
really good TV shows on Netflix that are
like originals and then like a lot more
the others that aren't that's my theory
we can talk about this later once we
finish talking about x-men Dark Phoenix
but my theory is that the streaming
model is bad for movies so that's why
there's it's just inherent doesn't it
doesn't work with movies so that's why
there are so many bad Netflix movies but
more to the point x-men Dark Phoenix the
this trailer is like nothing like what
the movies actually gonna be because
they're still basically editing it
together and also the VFX is probably
not done and they also moved the release
date because it was originally gonna be
released in February but now what they
did is that they moved
Elita battle angel out of competition
with you know Disney's Mary Poppins
Returns and now that Aleta is going to
release and know that in February and
Dark Phoenix is gonna be released in
June you know that in case it may be the
very last x-men movie ever made because
New Mutants is coming out in March you
know they tell you in film school that
the the final rewrite is in the editing
room exactly and it's a weird has so
many studios don't know what movie they
want to make until after it's filmed and
then put a lot of pressure on editors to
figure it out so face the fact even if
the script was a completely [ __ ]
different thing also they're just sort
of rewriting the they're also just
rewriting the they also rewrote the
ending and that's pretty much what they
reshot they rewrote the ending so that
they go through a time portal and then
go wait where are we now everything so
much more blue and gray and then cap
conversation help us defeat the Fanus I
was I was having a conversation about
this with other people at school
speaking of that you know twist endings
to things you know what's a really you
know what I really hate about the end
you know the one thing that I really
hated about Deadpool - the end credits
scene the end credits that was
absolutely garbage yeah it like bringing
back Vanessa was ruined the whole year
and like it just ruins the tone they're
going for with the rest of it and like
there's no if you introduced the
time-travel thing that you can just fix
then there's no emotional consequences
to anything you're actually [ __ ]
doing so and it also ruins the whole
rest of the supposed universe that
they've built because then like so I
basically like to pretend that that
scene doesn't exist I mean time-travel
worked in n Days of Future past because
it had such extreme limitations on how
it could work
mmm-hmm like you could only send
someone's mind into their body
you know they had with the rest of it
they had you know specific rules for the
rest of it but if you can just [ __ ]
jump through a door and go back in time
also the rules of the Deadpool to time
travel is really confusing because it
doesn't make a duplicate of himself he
ends up like with his future knowledge
Rhian habit inhibit then like how did
cable do that because cable wasn't born
yet well there's a different time travel
the same watch can do two different
types of time travel also I want to read
an article if I can find it
which is I might have read this earlier
but it's on art commercialism Deadpool -
in a culture of violence where it
basically blames you know like our
cultural obsession with violence quote
unquote is the stuff like they haven't
Deadpool - with all the violence and
they celebrates violence and all that
stuff yeah so what do you think does
Deadpool to celebrate violence I mean I
guess but then so does like every movie
that comes out now my answer is no
because van because Deadpool to remember
it's literally about how violence won't
solve your problems and about how you
know Deadpool just like lashes out at
everybody cuz he's grieving and he just
you know punches people and that doesn't
solve his problems and then the ending
is literally trying to get that boy to
not kill that guy oh yeah you're right
I'm an evil murderer it's weird how you
remember that movie better than I do
this is because I have a memory that you
which is a thing that you don't have
maybe it's because I'm a little
emaciated right now cuz I haven't had a
lot of like nutrients for the past two
weeks don't they give you like vitamin
suppositories to help you out in that
random weird place that you are right
now no they take me out into some kind
of bigger that way [ __ ] in a bucket well
they give you a suppositories when
you're asleep oh god I hope not
now I'm gonna be really paranoid and
check every morning now hey I only get
three hours of sleep
by morning it's too late I just I have
like a blanket and I just sleep in this
bathtub
what kind of blanket though a very thin
one it's it kind of has like a lot of
dog hair on it you know I keep thinking
you know I keep thinking about dark
phoenix and how it's gonna be like
honestly that kind of makes me sad
cuz like all there's knocking it there's
gonna be there's gonna be more exeunt
movies man
they're gonna keep making me know it's
unrecognizable no and it's the last one
in this franchise no no there's not
gonna be any more x-men movies there's
gonna be movies with x-men in them but
there's not gonna be any more x-men
movies well welcome to being a
spider-man fan this is why I don't like
wanna be a spider-man fan cuz being a
spider-man fan sucks
yeah well now you know our pain is cuz
we were really attached to this really
well put together franchise and then
they're like alright let's start it over
and then you're like all right maybe I
can find a way to love this and then
then they're like alright let's start
over again and you're like okay should I
just just not get attached because
alright that's my that's what it where
I'm I do it don't be attached to
anything I just do not get attached to
movie franchises anymore because I know
they're all extremely finite and we'll
probably get cancelled at the drop of a
hat if it means that like they can make
three extra dollars the capitalism so
like my friend that's why I don't care
about the Sony like spider-man universe
without spider-man in it I don't what
you're talking about I know it's not
gonna last long I'll get to venom movies
out of it and then I'll be happy and
then everyone else everything else will
just be a [ __ ] show and you're talking
about the Morbius movie from the
director of life is gonna be so really
good I can't wait for Jared Leto to act
like a weird [ __ ] on the set of this
movie to uh I mean it's like he you're a
joker as an excuse to just be
prick and then was like nothing can be a
good actor you can but good director
ah he was great Blade Runner 2014 jinx
he's good in that but because he was
directed by Denis Villeneuve Inge was
Deni also I know I intentionally
mispronounced it just that's my joke I'm
the one who mispronounces things
listen film film buffs always say Denis
Villeneuve so I'm gonna say Denis
Villeneuve a I cells been they say
Dennis Rodman just to get it really bad
but anyway he was great in that but like
I really great in the dune movie
remember on detta Dennis Rodman like
committed treason or whatever yes I do
actually it was when he starred in in
was in Space Jam she wasn't in Space Jam
no that was Michael Jordan what was
Dennis Rodman in it's like more people
know him for being a [ __ ] weirdo that
hangs out was like dictators than his
actual acting career he wasn't an actor
and I think he started off as a Dane
Cook in an action movie in early 2000
Dane Cook was in an action movie with
Dennis Rodman oh god that sounds awful
I'm pretty sure cyber monks oh God Dane
Cook has the [ __ ] funniest voice for
me who is ding it oh it's called Simon
Says with an S easy Oh anyway I see with
Dennis Rodman you guys might know him
you know he's a pretty famous basketball
player uh and like hello the whole
career thing but like um so I was in a
movie with him uh and it was an action
movie and like everyone really loved it
but like a so I'm gonna send you the
poster for this movie cuz Dennis Dennis
Rodman has the best just look of just
complete bored I'm honest
face oh there's a PD it's Rodman with
Donald Trump for celebrity pet
apprentice I guess I guess dennis has a
type yeah he likes um really really fat
dictators he likes people that look like
foodstuffs look at rags click on this
poster and it's not going is that Dane
Cook in the background I'm pretty sure
are you sure that's actually Dane Cook
in this movie I'm sure it is
why would grain cook be in an action
film I don't believe it yeah it stars
Dennis Rodman Dane Cook
oh look there's a whole Slyke 3-year
four paragraphs on his wikipedia called
legal troubles Broadman and his then
wife Carmen Electra were charged with
misdemeanors after police were notified
of domestic disturbance
each posted to $2,500 in bail and were
released with a temporary restraining
order placed on them he also have an
affair with Madonna
remember Carmen Electra remember how she
was like known for something at some
point in like 1999 no I don't remember
who that was or what she did oh my God
look at Carmen Electra's picture on her
on her Wikipedia page she looks like
like there's something I can't I can't
put it in words I have to just send you
this picture it looks like she's wearing
someone else's face on an old lady's
body listen do you see it you see it too
right it looks like it's like an A it
looks like an old lady who has like a 20
year old girls face like stapled on like
her neck is all like like lock twist
it's secretly the Joker her neck is all
wrinkly and like dark colors it's like
one of those matte like it's like the
mask that Arnold Schwarzenegger wore in
Total Recall yeah it's two weeks
it's scary weeks weeks what is carbonyl
like you look like that
what happened dump her face in the
Lazarus Pit but then forget to put the
rest of her in there why are you like
this
Brandon little Lazarus Pit is not not
the Batman one the other one that we
came up with it's Oh as a Lazarus Pit in
taunton Doctor Who know where it turns
you into giant into a giant scorpion
monster and also regenerates you is that
what happened to the rock I know it's
what happened to an old white British
guy who invented this machine in episode
of Doctor Who
number one the rock was a big scary
scorpion CGI man to be fair the CGI was
about as good as in that movie yeah
those are the things that put me off on
Doctor Who is that like I couldn't take
the effects seriously because they
reminded me so much of like Power
Rangers quality speaking of bad effects
did you know that the doctor is now a
woman and the fierce episode came out
last week I thought that happened like a
year ago
well she they they recast her a year ago
but they actually right he's the first
episode with her so was it like 90
minutes of just jokes of the doctor
going I used to have a penis but now I
don't know but there is joke in like the
first scene when she doesn't realize
that she's a woman yet where it's like
uh ma'am ma'am why are you here why are
you calling me men cuz you're a woman oh
I am doesn't suit me
what does it suit me like how do I made
about women before they'd make him a
redhead because I'm sorry I'm uh sorry
slept like well cuz like 20 minutes ago
I was a white hair Scotsman
I mean fairly that's a pretty good joke
yeah you know I kind of want to put
together a list of all the times that a
character in like a piece of fiction was
a had like red hair and freckles and
then was recast as something else I
swear to God Ellen was a redhead but
then she started you mangy I swear to
you I swear to you Hollywood has a thing
against redheads
I think they just dislike gingers and
before I know you're gonna make your
jokes of like well of course everyone
does
aye aye there you go yeah all right get
out of your system now so I can have the
rest of this conversation with you I
don't think that Hollywood is a thing
against redheads I just think you have a
thing against Hollywood I swear to you I
can put together so many examples of
people being recast as some other race I
think like there's some kind of like
rule that they don't tell the public
about that like producers and executives
know about where they if they see a
ginger character they go that's our free
slot to recast with a minority because
it'll add to the diversity of the cast
well I mean - you have a hint of an
argument there because gingers are the
widest of all people and to replace
somebody with a minority you always go
with the widest person to replace them
man first we had to go through all of
that [ __ ] at the beginning of the
last century now we're going through
this you're a minority we don't have any
representation man good no like the only
group of people that you can make fun of
for how they look and it's not racist at
all listen I don't want my kid growing
up to be a ginger no but I'm like I'm
serious though like if you bully a kid
in in middle school for being a ginger
you can't get in trouble for it because
he's white he's white but you can get
incredible for bullying for anything
well no one [ __ ] did when I was in
middle I have a lot of like were like
repressed anger for like all of the
people doing the soulless ginger joke
when I was like 12 like I got so goddamn
tired of that I thought about dyeing my
hair for a little while do it do it no
and I can't unless like acid I mean
maybe I could search around the the
bathroom and see if there's something in
here I could use do it I don't think
they'll let me waste my time on that
though can do it and run the clock do it
why are they letting you do this because
it equals ad revenue not four well yeah
for you obviously cuz you're gonna be
releasing this nightmare trainwreck in
like two weeks so you take forever to
edit these because you're lazy I think
they just want the channel and they want
me to do what I have to do who are they
the guards who are the guards I don't
know their name they wear masks well
listen if you know their names
you can seduce one of them and then you
can have sex with them and like convince
them to let you go
thank your feminine wiles I'm not enough
of a trap for that yet well got a comb
for your hair and then you'll be a
trapped I comb my hair every day while I
used tubes but I you you always give me
so much [ __ ] about not combing my hair
and I'm like I do it like like twice a
day no you don't Linnell exactly I'm
worried that I'm gonna wake up and find
out that there's a mold growing on me
from being in this bathtub I'll start to
look like Carmen Electra no you will
become venom these maybe then I could
fight my way out of here and see the Sun
but like shitty venom um like boring
venom like ginger venom
ginger venom is just carnage Jon
Arbuckle is an in cell
I have several follow-up questions on
how you came to that conclusion yeah
yeah what a wonderful discussion we just
had is that dip is the podcast over now
well I don't know what do you think hold
on let me ask hey is the podcast over
yet
cuz the greasy straight the greasy
strangler is on Amazon the the guards
kind of like tapping his wrists like
like he has a watch even though he
doesn't have a watch why what does that
mean I think he's telling me that I have
to get back to work
why dad because I have a I have to
complete what what I was asked to why
because I will die if I don't what's the
problem David
yes I'm scared
good you should be
I'm not doing this I'm just along for
the ride why would you help me well for
one cuz I'm a thousand miles away
well I can't you sell any wouldn't help
do you think anybody would believe me
that you're being kidnapped and being
forced to make youtube videos somebody
would
[Music]
[Music]